[MUSIC PLAYING]
Each season, I want to introduce you
to some new aspect of what we're calling home.
And in season two, I wanted to add the attic to this.
[FOOTSTEPS]
I was lucky enough to direct this episode
and got to design the attic.
And I remember showing this episode to my family.
And they all gasped when the door opened.
[DOOR CLICKS OPENS]
Where's Jericho?
I don't know.
Well, you'll stay here till you remember.
The attic has a symbolic representation that it's
the highest point in the house.
And now Leanne is in the highest point in the house.
[CLICKING]
With regard to Sean and Leanne, I
think that they've always had some kind of honesty
about them.
They're honest with each other.
Tell me who you're looking for.
Jericho.
Jericho died, Mr. Turner.
Sean is drawn to this person that he can tell the truth to.
And because of the kindness he shows her,
it seems that positive things are happening to him.
Did you put scotch bonnets in this?
Hmm, you guessed.
Darling, you can taste.
It's a very interesting dynamic because there's kind of almost
like liaisons -- alliances that are being made in this episode,
Dorothy on one side--
What did you do with--
--and Leanne and Sean start to become an alliance on another.
What did you do?
And you see that the stakes are extremely high for this family.
This is too far.
Nothing is too far.
[MUSIC PLAYING]